-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
The Biden administration
last week called
for new regulations
on regional banks.
I'm kidding. We're only
doing fun stuff today.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Regional banks.
Get outta here!
[ Laughter and applause ]
A Manhattan grand jury voted
on Thursday
to indict former President Trump
for allegedly making
a hush money payment
to adult film star
Stormy Daniels.
But if you think this is the end
for Donald Trump,
I have a bus to sell you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
After it was reported
on Thursday
that a Manhattan grand jury
had voted to indict him,
former President Trump
had dinner at Mar-a-Lago
with former
First Lady Melania Trump.
It was a poignant moment
in their relationship
and Trump and Melania
very tenderly and lovingly
split the check.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Trump ]
So, your half is $38.50.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
is set tomorrow
to be fingerprinted
and photographed
and then the next step
will be to sit back
and see how many cold cases
that solves.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"We, uh --
[ Cheering ]
Chief, you're not going
to believe this.
We got news on the
Westchester Strangler.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's lawyers
are reportedly
considering asking
to have his trial moved
from Manhattan to Staten Island.
Ah, yes, the Mar-a-Lago
of New York.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What are they going
to sentence him to,
a parade?
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Trump's lawyers want
to have Trump's trial moved
from Manhattan to Staten Island.
Normally, if you want
to move something
from Manhattan to Staten Island,
you just throw it
in a trash can.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Baze.
Alex -- make your letters
out to Alex Baze.
[ Laughter ]
The Justice Department and FBI
reportedly have evidence
that former President Trump
possibly obstructed
the investigation
into classified documents found
at his Mar-a-Lago home.
Trump is reportedly
still digesting the news
and the documents.
[ Laughter ]
A couple in Michigan recently
pulled into a Costco parking lot
to give birth to their baby
while on their way
to the hospital.
They also picked up
some snacks and toiletries
because how often do you find
a parking space at Costco?
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Just breathe, honey,
I'm going to run in."
[ Laughter ]
Today with zoologist
Jane Goodall's 89th birthday.
Her friends threw a party
and their feces.
[ Laughter, oohs, and applause ]
McDonald's --
[ Laughter ]
McDonald's has reportedly
closed down
its corporate offices
temporarily
to prepare for layoffs,
so, if you were looking
to burglarize them,
now might be a good time.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, today was Don't Go
to Work Unless It's Fun Day.
But don't worry, it is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
[ Cheering ]
We're off and running.